- Now we all know the only person
who is just as important as
the Emmy nominees is
the emcee of the show.
So let's look back at some of
our favorite Emmy award show
hosts and their most memorable moments.
Take a look.
The Emmy awards have tried
hosts from all across the
entertainment aisles;
actors, singers, comedians,
even a screenwriter was the very first
host of the Emmy awards in 1949
and soon followed by some
early television stars,
including Lucille Ball and Desi Arnaz
Ed Sullivan, Fred Astaire
and Frank Sinatra.
In 1975, CBS went with no main hosts,
but rather 10 mistresses of ceremony.
Johnny Carson holds the record
for most Emmys hosted at four.
While Ellen DeGeneres,
Joey Bishop, John Forsythe,
Danny Thomas and Jimmy Kimmel
each have hosted three times
in recent years, late night hosts
and SNL alums like Andy
Samberg, Stephen Colbert
and Jimmy Fallon have
traded off hosting duties.
Fallon opened the Emmy ceremony
with a brilliant epic song
and dance number in 2010,
featuring Tina Fey,
John Hamm
the cast of Glee,
and Betty White has been
called the greatest opening
to the Emmys ever.
And this year there's a new,
funny man up for the gig.
Cedric, the entertainer
has been making us
laugh for over 30 years.
You've seen him in Barbershop,
Johnson Family Vacation,
the Steve Harvey show,
and most currently on the hit
show 'The Neighborhood' on CBS
And he already has hosting
experience under his belt,
including a season of 'Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire?'
We bet this king of comedy is ready to
hold court at the Emmys.
Please welcome this year's
73rd annual Emmy awards host.
(applause)
Cedric, the Entertainer!
(crowd cheering)
(lively music)
- What's up?
That's you, you're-
this is beautiful
- Well,
you're-
- You have great jewelry too.
Like you're really doing it, Drew.
You got like great jewelry on
and see guys, we don't really get to dress
like really nice jewels.
- I'm skipping right to
what are you gonna do?
What are you gonna wear? What'd you think?
- I mean, you know, it is,
it's one of those things where
you think you can get away
with just the black tux and the classic,
you know, Gable look
you know, with the pose
and the smoldering eyes.
I've been working on
that. My eyes smoldered.
(audience laughs)
That's all you think
you want to do. Right?
But now fashion is going a lot forward.
So, you know, I'm actually
going to change a few times.
I'm gonna come out with some.
- Oh, I love that.
(audience cheers)
I love that
Cedric
Give them what they want.
- Exactly. Give it to them.
I'm giving them Magnum.
(Cheers)
it works.
- I love that you get the call to host
what happens, what takes place?
What's the circumstances?
And what goes through your mind?
- I was like, you know, I was
out pitching another show.
So, and they like getting you, like,
you got a call from this
very important person.
And I was like (chortles) this is the one.
He was like, Hey yeah, the
thing you tried to sell us.
That's a no, but would you
want to host the Emmys?
So, I was like
hell yeah
(cheering)
so I was excited
that was good. It was one of these.
It was a bad call. Then it
turned into a good call.
All in one call.
- I think the Emmys is
one of my favorite shows
because I think it's really
representative of the collective
of the way we're really watching.
- Yes, I call this the television,
this is the prom for us.
This is our night for people
who work in television
and do this as for a living.
- Cedric, I know you're
going to be the greatest
because I've never heard
someone say, this is our prom.
- It's a coolness that
happens in Hollywood on,
on those nights when
everybody's kind of dressed up
and you know, it's this coolness
where we all kind of like
(tongue clicks)
- Yeah, listen up, enjoy the moment.
- Yeah, no, let's turn it.
Let's do the other thing.
Let's, I want to be
shirts off jacket-less.
Yeah, we got to turn up, old school.
- So your good friend,
Anthony Anderson is
nominated for lead actor
in a comedy series. Are
you so happy for him?
- And you know, and this is probably,
I think Anthony's eighth nomination
and so he's never won one.
So with me being the host, I'm like, bro,
you leaving out of there
with something, I don't know.
He's got to get somebody's
Emmy for, you know
lighting or something and be like,
"Hey, here you go, dawg. Take that."
(crowd laughs)
- No, you're already on a
juggernaut show for CBS,
'The Neighborhood'
going into season four.
I mean.
How does that feel?
- I mean, it's very exciting,
One, I don't take it for granted.
I've been doing this a
long time and blessed
to be in television a long time.
And so we just really blessed
to have the opportunity to
come back and just to be
able to make people laugh,
to come into their homes
on Monday nights on CBS,
Monday nights, eight o'clock guys
Shameless plug.
- Thank you, Cedric, the entertainer.
Be sure to catch the
fourth season of the show
The Neighborhood on September 20th on CBS
also streaming on paramount plus
and tune in to see him
host the 73rd
Emmy Awards
September 19th, on CBS.